wallic welcome Dr Wallach well thank you
so much Rebecca for the kind
introduction you did such a complete job
I don't have to do anything I just sit
here you did such a great job
sorry and of course that's the story
today is that the rate of deaths in
young people in America are going up
very very steadily very rapidly going up
and this is simply because of lack of
nutrients in some cases interference
with absorption
by consumption of glutens and fatal
Pyrenees or something we burn around
oats and buckwheat those things have to
go uh eat like an Asian rice and beans
and potatoes and that kind of stuff
vegetables
you can add 25 to 50 healthy areas your
life just doing that
but
um it is terrible when you look at the
number of people who die in First World
countries like the United States okay
and they're dying from nutritional
deficiencies
lamps only need three minerals to make
maximum yields for a farm
okay NPK
and that's what the commercial
fertilizers are meant from
or made from okay NPK
we need 60 minerals including NPK but we
also need
okay 57 other minerals
and so it's very important to understand
we have to pay some special attention
here to make sure we're getting
everything and this is why people like
the hunzas who live in the Himalayan
Mountains their life expectancy is 120
many live to be 130 140 150 our life
expectancies in America we have more
doctors per capita telling anybody else
or life expectancy 75 what their life
expectancy is only 75.
and that's because we're not getting the
nutrients we need to maintain
our health and provide the nutrients for
our heart to work and our lungs to work
and our liver to work and our kidneys
work and our muscles work and our bones
are working and so forth
and this is why the medical profession
does so well let's just look at one
category of diseases that doctors deal
with this is one little category okay
this is due to
um
myelin white matter deficiencies in the
brain and each year in America and just
for Alzheimer's disease alone we spend
345 billion with a B 345 billion dollars
a year just to treat the symptoms of
Alzheimer's disease another myelin
deficient white matter deficiency of the
human brain is Ms multiple sclerosis and
gambarre syndrome which is multiple
sclerosis of spinal cord we spend 85
billion dollars here just to treat the
symptoms of that one then Parkinson's
disease okay which has the same thing
that Alzheimer's disease MS and
gameration Syndrome have but also has
the Tremors okay that makes it
Parkinson's disease we spend 52 billion
dollars a year to treating the symptoms
of Parkinson's disease not prevailing it
the life expectancy of somebody with a
diagnosis of Parkinson's disease is
eight to ten years
no matter what your age is your
expectancy you had diagnoses life
expectancy is eight to ten years
um let's see here we also have FTD
frontal temporal dementia which is kind
of a variation on Alzheimer's disease as
the name implies it's the frontal area
of the brain the temporal area of the
brain and these are parts of the brain
they're newly involved with Alzheimer's
disease we spend 7.28 billion dollars a
year just treating that one and then ALS
okay
um email hey melotrophic lateral
sclerosis okay this is a loss of the
white matter of the
um
brain and spinal cord but they call it
lateral sclerosis because
the outside layers okay the spinal cord
are just connected to if you've lost all
these nerves and it's also called Lou
Gehrig's Disease as 1.02 billion dollars
a year just to treat the symptoms of Lou
Gehrig disease ALS all of these I'm
looking for because we we have this
program we put together okay and
we uh we have a great great you know you
always have a first
patient that everything goes perfect and
right because you've put all together
all the newest information this and the
other in that patient and this is true
for us with Parkinson's disease and I
know we're putting we're rapidly working
24 7 putting together a case report here
it can be published okay with the
um see here these
um
yeah and and of course his Parkinson's
disease saying this is going to save so
many lives and so many people's life
um which I say quality the quality of
life is just going to go up amazing and
historically it it got to people didn't
matter how rich you were how poor you
were when you exercise or not when you
got Parkinson's disease you were in
trouble okay because it went One
Direction and within like I said eight
to ten years were dead that was the
scenario well we're changing all that
because we have a wonderful
um uh let's just say a wonderful patient
who just cooperated with us
uh all the way and as a she and we had a
nice conversation with her yesterday oh
my gosh let me tell you she is one
healthy healthy healthy person and
um she was getting treated by a very
famous Medical Clinic I'm not going to
give you their name right now but it'll
be of course in the report when it comes
out here in a couple of days
and um but basically
um they treat her the same way as they
do all Parkinson's patients and every
year for 11 years she was re-diagnosed
and confirmed that she still had
Parkinson's disease
every year for 11 years then we gave her
our program for two and a half months
and she went for her 12th year annual
physical
negative
and they redid it up negative okay and
so it's freaking him out and they just
told her okay well just keep doing what
you're doing we'll see you next year
you would think they'd be falling all
over themselves want to know what she
did did she do something different or
anything no they weren't interested I
found that very interesting okay so
anyway I'm very excited about this
because this is going to be one of the
greatest stories this year okay one of
the greatest Traders we have many many
thousands of great stories okay then
we've helped people with nutrition but
this is one a very specific health issue
okay that we know we can prevent and
reverse
okay with a nutritional program
we've proven it and this this uh what
makes it so wonderful is this Clinic
that she was going to is so famous
than anything that this Clinic says
everybody believes and rightfully so
because they do a great job
they do a great job and so we have to
Pat him on the back and say thank you
thank you thank you for doing a great
job and keeping all the records correct
and um and when there was a negative
okay not a negative negative but a
negative a report on the disease is
suddenly now after 11 years it went away
and they were honest about it
particularly just said okay the same but
they were honest about it okay so we got
to give them credit for that
so
um then you look at
um sudden heart deaths
this is happening and more and more and
more in younger kids I mean we're
talking about kids who are
six years old 10 years old
uh 10 12 years old uh teenagers they're
12 to 20 years old young adults 25 years
old they're dying of hypertrophic
cardiopathy heart disease and many of
them are heavy exercisers they sweat out
nutrients
and they don't supplement completely or
if they do supplement completely they're
eating the gluten and fatal patterns
from buckwheat they can't absorb the
nutrition and so they're dying of these
nutritional efficiencies in the form of
hypertrophy cardiomopathy heart disease
it's not a genetic thing okay it's a
very simple disease it's been reported
in every species of animal you can think
of okay and it has to do in every case
with nutritional deficiencies a
particular class of nutrients okay we'll
go over that once this report is out we
don't want to preempt the report too
much too much
but this is going to make
life which they say easier for millions
of people around the world this is going
to make life easier
for patients who already have these
health issues because with a supplement
program we can reverse these health
issues these hypertrophic cardiomphic
heart disease these are reversible okay
very quickly within weeks okay it's a
terrible terrible terrible potentially
fatal disease but it's easily prevented
we can wipe it out so you don't hear
about it anymore and once you have it we
can actually wipe it out by getting rid
of all the bad foods the maximize
absorption take your 90 essential
nutrients and throw an extra of that
nutrient we'll get into that of course
when this paper comes out we don't want
to take away from the shock
okay when this paper comes out it'll
blow everybody's mind okay and I'm very
very excited about that and I know uh
Becca's working on that 37-20
she has so many things she's got going
but yeah this is a priority because
we're going to save kids we're going to
save animals we're going to save seniors
we're going to save Humanity with this
report and so I'm so so so very excited
about it okay over to you Rebecca
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
there there's so many things
that happen because of
no minerals
that is correct
so the the heart disease and then so
demyelinization that's more cholesterol
than minerals though am I yeah a
deficiency in cholesterol doctors say
cholesterol is bad you shouldn't have it
it's very silly
like an egg that's like
perfectly formed I mean
there there's there's no well there can
be some human intervention in that egg
but I mean it's created it's part of
creation
and all you have to do is crack it open
and
heat it up a little bit cook it a little
bit without too much folks you don't
want to you don't want to overcook your
eggs what happens when you overcook your
eggs Dr Wallach
well if you overcook your eggs it
actually causes problems with your heart
your nerves your brain your white matter
of your brain your myelin and when
people get these demyelinating diseases
okay including Alzheimer's disease is
one of them okay it's because they're
cooking their eggs too much or not
eating eggs at all
overcooking it actually changes the
cholesterol within the egg yeah it's not
available not available to do its job
right now in a normal perfectly normal
human brain depending on the Zone you're
talking about you're looking at 25 to 50
percent
of that location is cholesterol in your
brain
25 to 50 and so if you're killing all
your sources of cholesterol
okay by overcooking them or not eating
them okay because doctors say oh no no
cholesterol you get lack of your
arteries that's not true
it's fried cholesterol that gives you
the plaque in the arteries it's it's
fried fats it's fried butter anything
super heated okay
um fried chicken fried fish
that will cause you big trouble okay
including all these things going on with
your arteries and and so on but if you
just cook once they say softly okay
and so this is where you just want to in
fact I like to poach eggs soft soft
scrambled in butter
and I've been doing this for 75 years
and I didn't know a lot because I was
only nine years old at the time but I
knew that people who lived in certain
countries did better than we and I was
trying to follow all the stuff they were
doing and it worked
okay I was only nine years old but I
knew there was something going on I knew
that when we gave animals certain
nutrients they did better okay we took
away those nutrients they did bad okay
and so this is a nine-year-old figuring
all this out and of course
um
the the
um study we did with that 21 million
Grant from NIH
at the Washington University in St Louis
okay it's uh in the it's in the
Smithsonian Institute as a National
Treasure
okay we're talking about the diseases of
exotic animals the diseases of exotic
animals of course that was the
Publishers that's the that's the title
they gave it okay and that probably
wouldn't have been my choice but but it
worked the diseases of exotic animals
and um in that book
it shows all the diseases that are
preventable
that there are no genetically
transmitted diseases and it freaked
everybody out and it sells for twenty
five thousand or thirty five thousand
dollars you can still get them beat up
you may have to pay three thousand five
thousand eight thousand ten thousand
dollars for BF copy
okay but now we have
okay a
um new published version of the disease
of exotic animals called epigenetics
it's just a whole new science of every
genetics that's me in 1976 with a
um monkey from Yorkies Primary Center
the first non-human case of cystic bro
so to be one of the most terrible birth
defects in humans and we're able to
reverse it with a simple nutritional
formula and it freaked everybody out so
that's why we have the book heavy
genetics okay and um it sells for 25
bucks not twenty five thousand but just
25 and so it's available everybody was
no matter what your budget is to add 25
to 50 helpful years to your family's
life it's worth 25 bucks
oh absolutely Dr Wallach and you can get
Dr wallach's books at d r j
wallick.com that is
drjwalik.com or for those of you outside
of the United States
amazon.com is a great place to get Dr
wallach's books where they are able to
more affordably ship them to you
so we have lots of questions Dr Wallach
and one of the questions that we have is
I was mentioning that if the minerals
are not in the soil
then it's not in the food well
pertaining to our products and getting
the minerals in I think is where they're
coming from the question is if the soil
is depleted of essential minerals then
how are supplements enriched with
essential minerals or vitamins and does
this require a chemical additive that is
a great question
okay it was very simple you go back to
the old Bible the Old Testament we're
talking over 3000 years ago okay
and they knew then now they didn't know
all the science but there was an
observation there were places where
people live longer
the land flowing with milk and honey
okay now the milk that they're talking
about was not cow's milk goat's milk
camel milk llama milk it was glacial
milk the glaciers up on top of the
mountains grinding up the rocks and The
Rock Dust was white so the when the rock
dust got into the streams coming down
the mountains it looked like milk to the
people in The Valleys it looked like
milk coming down the mountain so that's
what I was calling the people who lived
the longest were the healthiest lived in
the land flowing with milk and honey
because they looked that as milk okay so
that's why we have that story and
when you look at glacial milk it's not
the same from Mountain to Mountain to
Mountain is different because every
mountain is made out of different rocks
and so when you look at the book Rare
Earth Ventures rarest ventures in
chapter 10 which is entitled glacial
milk
and has several I don't know three or
four or five different
um
analyzes of glacial milk and shows you
they're quite different
and we looked around the world for six
months before we found sources we found
a couple of sources in the United States
we found a couple of sources in Asia
okay where we have a minimum of 75 to 85
minerals in our products
75 to 85 minerals in our products when
you look at most modern mineral
supplements they've got maybe three
minerals eight minerals 12 minerals
that's about it we have 75 to 78
on the average never less than 75.
so our 75 minerals being consumed
healthier than three minerals Maine
Coons of course that's a no-brainer okay
and that's why those people live so long
and when you look at the hunzas which
come from the Himalayan mountains which
has the
um a great great source of
um uh the land flowing of milk and honey
their life expectancy is 120. they don't
have one medical doctor and when you
look at the United States we are the
medical doctor king and queen of the
world we have more medical doctors per
person than anybody else in the world
and yet our life expectancy is only 75.
in Huns and they don't have any medical
doctors whatsoever their life
expectancies 120 and many lived 130 140
150 because you're getting these
minerals from the mountains in the form
of glacial milk which say drink is water
okay to make their wine out of it as
well okay they also use it for
irrigating their crops in their Gardens
so they're getting these minerals and
now they don't know all the science they
don't know the science they just know
the people who are drinking that water
and using that water of irrigation live
longer okay that's what they know they
don't know all the science behind it
and so that's why this book The Rare
Earths have been encouraged is so
important that's why the book
um epigenetics is so important
and I what can I say I just get
breathless when I think about how much
we know
and how much we're making available to
our
Families Our Associates or our customers
um and so on this is something they're
going to add 25 to 50 healthier it's
your life it's very economical if you do
the youngevity program as an associate
and so you're helping other people with
their thing and you're training them
um and you become one of our Associates
you have tax breaks and you can put in
your in your
let's see what do you call it your
business
um uh thing your expenses yeah the
business and OKAY model the business
model is that what you're thinking of no
I'm thinking the business table your
your business records okay you can say
we're going to make these these minerals
available to our people okay who are
members of this Business Association and
it's a tax deduction so when you're when
you're getting these minerals and you
put it in your
your tax
code okay your little thing is
it's attached right off okay
that you will be able to save an
enormous amount of money and add 25 to
50 healthier I mean that's a win-win-win
situation
and people say well my doctor said I can
get everything I need this but anyway
well that was true
when people are getting their water from
glacial milk it was true before
electricity came along
huh electricity has killed more people
than all the wars we've been in since
the beginning of time
and it's been indirect killing okay
because prior to electricity what do we
use for fuel Becca
yeah wooden coal and what did we do with
wood ashes and coal action every morning
do we just throw them in the garbage can
no probably Sprint them out somewhere in
the yard whether it was in the garden
flower beds somewhere yeah you put them
in the garden and we put them in small
Fields you have small gardens which are
maybe a half an acre an acre in your
backyard and they put the wood answer
coal ashes there and they actually made
and they would put the wood ashes and
coal ashes into our stew into our soup
on our salads because they couldn't
they're poorer people they couldn't
afford a big expensive things and so
they're just putting the wood ahead and
shows and coal ashes under our food as a
spice okay as well
and this is why the slaves the old slave
days in America lived to be 85 90 95 100
110 120 and the plantation owners would
die in their 50s and 60s now why was
that well that's because the slaves were
using wooden and coal ashes not only as
a condiment on their foods but also in
their Gardens okay so the crops they
were growing their their onions and
tomatoes and corn and stuff like that
were second of those meals they ate the
plants that had sucked up all the
minerals they're getting all those
minerals whereas the owners of the
plantations they're trying to eat like
Europeans and they were just eating
steak that was it they would just eat
steak for breakfast lunch and dinner
and that's why they died in their 50s
and 60s
I like steak doctor well that's fine
that's a really good thing that I take
my supplements off yeah but see you
don't just eat steak I know you eat
vegetables you eat fruit you you eat
other
um things like uh poultry
um
you eat fish all kinds of stuff you
don't just eat steak but that's what the
plantation owners were doing they were
just steak was the sort of thing that
everybody said okay you're rich if
you're going to eat steak for every meal
of also eat steak two three times a day
and that's why they die in their 50s and
60s
and and the slaves they lived 110 120.
but it's because the the steak didn't
it's was either overcooked or it didn't
include the minerals right okay you have
to appreciate meat only has a certain
amount of minerals in it meat only has
three or four minerals in it
okay okay an onion can have 24 minerals
in it
compared depending on the ground that
it's grown in that's correct but a steak
only has pure formula most of the
minerals in an animal occurs and stored
in the liver
and again the livers were given to the
Plantation Slaves
they would eat deliverers even when they
would clean fish they would give the
fish place to Plantation owner they
would eat Deliver Us from the fish and
that's where most of the minerals are
stored in animals is in the livers
and so that's why they live so long
because they're getting the minerals
whereas the the plantation owners were
looking at
they were looking at what if I'm saying
they wanted to have the
um
more of the cream of the crop but they
were forgetting the crop doctor yeah
we'll see what they wanted to they
wanted to have the acknowledgment that
they're in the same
area as the big plantation owners in
Europe and that kind of stuff okay
whereas the poor people are eating
livers and and um you know the the um
drumstick I don't know that it has
anything to do with with as far as
demographics or
or income or anything but the fact of we
live in a time now Dr well like where
you either don't want to waste a thing
or you live in a very wasteful type
environment
because I know growing up we didn't want
to waste a thing
if we grew it
whether it was animal or vegetable we
wanted to make sure we used every single
part of that we didn't want anything to
go to waste and you were mentioning how
you know you were a farm kid and I have
I have a confession Dr Wallach I'm a
farm kid too which is not part of the
confession
but I was paying more attention to the
ingredients and the minerals and the
protein fat carbohydrate ratios in my
animals feed than I was for myself
and I think that's what got me in
trouble
because I was more concerned about
taking care of them
and had completely forgotten about
myself
you know you just thought like doctor
said well just eat well you know your
farm fresh food and you're getting
everything you need well that was true
when not always but it was almost always
true when people are using wood and coal
the ceiling point of wood answer coal
ashes into the gardens into the food but
once you into electricity certainly now
that concept wasn't correct anymore
because the source of meals we had used
for thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of years went
away almost overnight
and then living in Phoenix Dr Wallach we
didn't have a lot of wood burning
so we had no ashes
that's right it was hot and you were
sweating
we were that's another thing yes we were
sweating so whatever minerals were going
in were being sweated out I remember
seeing my dad my brother they would be
out working because we we had a peach
orchard and they'd be out working and
their t-shirts would always have these
lines
you know the dark t-shirts have these
white lines and now that I know that
those were the minerals that were
sweating out of their bodies
that's correct
think about it folks if you got
something coming out and it's essential
to thrive
you got to be putting it more putting
more in than what you're taking having
sweat out
and that's what Dr wallach's
message is all about is intentionally
giving the body what it needs so that it
can Thrive because being proactive
is so much easier and cheaper than being
reactive and Dr Wallach for for those
that are on the radio because we still
are being broadcasted on radio programs
and we want to say hello to ksco and
k-o-m-y listeners thank you so much for
joining us continuing to join us
as we bring this program to you daily
with Doc
Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time I
don't know if that's when they're airing
it but we are here live in the zoom and
we invite you to join us as well at
Daily withdogzoom.com
and Dr Wallach we have some hands up so
let's go ahead and get to some questions
hey
and first I would like to invite Donald
to the screen with us hello Donald
welcome back
go ahead and unmute yourself if you
would please
how are you doing yes sir how can I help
you I'm calling you you back regarding
the dog Vegas the original 19 pound
Pomeranian Spitz mixed dog in March of
this year we started him on a
plethora of vitamins arthrodex I-26
selenium Z radical and then you suggest
we put minerals on his spine on his back
well the minerals on his spine as the
back has removed his cyst that was on
his head
that persists but his he has a huge
wavering of appetite so you suggest to
be you know turned into canned dog food
and the original canned Alex we did like
we found a medicated one and right away
he kept he started eating it and that
lasted for two months and in the last
four last four weeks he the the customer
likes to feed him
um peas frozen peas carrots broccoli a
mixture to try to find what he will eat
and he turns his nose at most everything
right now
and so he's not eating he's down to
about 15 pounds but holding that pretty
steady
okay well you have to appreciate the
dogs are carnivores they eat meat
they're not big on peas and carrots and
onions and stuff like that so you can't
expect them to do that it's kind of
ground up fine and it's mixed in with
the
canned dog food they'll eat it because
it's in there okay but they're not gonna
if you throw some peas into you know
some hamburger they'll kind of push the
peas off to the side and eat the
hamburger okay that's the nature of a
carnivore okay and so and also
they're getting more minerals they're
going to eat less
they're gonna eat less so they're
getting more minerals because when
people and animals have a behavior
called taika where they just eat and eat
and eat and eat and they gain weight is
because they're minimally deficient
and the behavior is called Pica p-i-c-a
okay and so that's not uncommon of when
you have a pet that you're giving lots
of minerals to that they're going to eat
less of the commercial
cat food dog food bird food whatever it
might be because you're getting all the
minerals and so they don't have a
mineral deficiency so they're not
craving so they don't have a pica
situation okay so that's not no it's not
unusual
to see a reduced food consumption when
you're giving them minerals okay
right so the so the client's wondering
is the minerals actually keeping her dog
alive because the dog was had a liver
cancer diagnosis
had liver cancer diagnosis yep
okay yeah and of course it may have been
a correct diagnosis because there's
times when you can actually overwhelm
cancer and make it go away and survive
it
um but uh it's one of those things where
uh it's not unusual
to add again say uh when you look at the
1900 the turn of the 20th century
um when household pets dogs their
average lifespan in a house is only
three to four years
okay well when they came out with canned
dog food okay in 1900 suddenly now the
life expectancy jumped to 12 to 15 years
because you're getting all the vitamins
and minerals added to the ground up meat
and stuff like that that was in the
canned dog food so they're getting a
more complete thing
compared with table straps
okay it might really be nice for the dog
you're just giving the dog steak which
is worse because it's just
high phosphorus diet and no none of the
real vitamins and minerals
so my my suggestion now is to that we
should really focus on just just putting
out the canned dog food and leaving it
out and
and not interfering him with any other
choices and give it to give it a whole
highly supplemented dog food and then
don't forget don't forget our arthradex
okay I said one scoop I think it's a one
scoop for 12 or 15 pounds whatever it is
and um uh that's really sort of a gem or
medium sized and small size pets of all
kind whether it's a parrot or a dog or a
cat
or it might be uh iguana okay okay and
so this is we've been doing this a long
time and so we see this this pattern
that has developed so we know that the
animals are gonna eat less when they're
getting the Arthur decks because they're
getting all these nutrients and so
they're not hungry
hunger Pica p-i-c-a is a behavior that
drives you to eat more because your body
is looking for those nutrients okay if
you live in a place where there's no
copper in the soil you're going to have
certain problems
okay you can be anemic or you have
plenty of iron in your diet and no
copper you're still going to get anemia
because your your red blood cells and
your bone marrow needs more than just
more than just iron
so this is this is why we came up with
the books this is why we came up with
the CDs the DVDs is why we came up with
all these different why do you have 600
products well like well because there's
several thousand different issues out
there okay and just to have one product
would take care of all those
the pill would be as big as a basketball
and you do a lot of licking on that so
you get rid of that in one day and so we
learned that we have to have these in
various combinations okay so we we came
up with the healthy rain and hard pack
the Healthy Start pack which has a 90
essential nutrients in it and then we
have the secret sauces which have these
other nutrients in there that prevent
and reverse certain pathologies now if
that person or that pet has that
pathology given the hell they ran a hard
pack the Healthy Start pack whatever it
is and then you give them that's that um
Secret Sauce is necessary to deal with
that issue and so that's how we designed
our system
okay so I hope that answers all
questions
thank you
all right thank you Donald thank you
very much and
I know my dogs love love love
the the arthrodex Dr Wallach well most
dogs love it
yeah so we choose a we choose a dog food
that has very few ingredients and then
we just load it up with the arthrodex
and make sure that they're getting good
proteins good fats good carbohydrates
and lots of arthroducts
um and and they don't so think about it
there are some dogs that are and people
that just want to eat eat all the time
and some
of either you get in the way of their
food they get aggressive
well I raised Rottweilers Dr Wallach I
don't have a single aggressive
Rottweiler
in my home
nor have I had one
and it's because they're getting those
nutrients they don't have to fight for
their food and they even share the same
food bowl so imagine that folks for for
those that um
yeah
so yeah we have four big Rottweilers
they all share the same food
bites they love to lick the bowl we just
keep it full and nobody nobody has
issues so it it's really
it was it really was a game changer when
we found the arthrit X and started
adding that into their food
it really was so thank you for bringing
that into the youngevity fold Dr Wallach
and the products that are offered
let's next go to Phyllis who has a
question Phyllis go ahead and unmute
yourself
all right well hi Dr Wong it's always
great to talk with you
good to talk with you what's up well I
do want to say our cats love the
arthritics and they're very peaceful and
beautiful intelligent creatures I give
the nutrients all credit
um I have a client who has a question
about distilled water and she wants to
know what you think about drinking
distilled water
okay
um distilled water is a hungry water
it doesn't like to be distilled so it's
going to pull
minerals from you and you're going to
lose a lot of minerals in your
urine and sweat if you're drinking just
still water that's your only source of
water
if you're going to use distilled water I
would add
a couple of ounces per quart
of our plant minerals
it has 75 minerals on it that's going to
take a calm it down so it's not hungry
water it's not going to suck all the
minerals out of you
okay but you do need water okay and of
course
um uh it's one of those things where
when you sweat when you exercise or
you're sweating it's hot I'm not
exercising but it's 100 it's almost 100
degrees here in California right now so
I'm sweating just sitting here in a
short sleeve shirt and shorts and I'm
sweating because of the temperature and
the humidity and so I'm going to up my
Minerals today I'm going to add more
minerals so it's not kind of just do the
same thing all the time but you know
regardless of how much exercise you did
you're you're raking the lawn unloading
a truck with a shovel kind of stuff
you're sweating you need the rebounds
okay with 100 nutrients 100 nutrients
175 minerals and 25 bonds amino acids
and so we go through a lot of rebounds
in this household okay we go through a
lot of rebound at night we'll pop two of
the cans uh pop molten put in the
refrigerator so in the morning I'm going
to take them out of the refrigerator all
the all the carbonation is gone I'll
have one with breakfast the other one
half and one the second one until
lunchtime the second half of the second
one do the recipe noon okay so you're
getting all those minerals but there's
no carbonation in it but when I leave
the house I'll put three or four of
these sticks with 100 nutrients in it in
my pocket okay and
um we also have another way to do that
okay it's called
that's at the
a mineral sticks okay so we have two
ways to get the minerals the mineral
sticks and the rebound
um
depending on what's going on and we're
going to go to a you know like a big
restaurant I'll take the middle sticks
with me
it's you know not as abusive or as
offensive to the rest of the eaters that
have this stick they're doing something
like that I just tear the top off and
it's it's done okay so we have two ways
to get the minerals uh when you're
eating out okay I'm having friends
already giving them the options how they
want the minerals so you don't have to
have this we're not going to break your
leg if you don't take it but we advise
you do take this because it's going to
you know potentially add many healthful
years to life and who knows if you have
certain health issues
um you can reverse those health issues
because there's no genetic health issues
most of them are just simple nutritional
efficiencies and let's see if we can't
help you and so it's always good to you
know and become people when people come
visit you introduce them to the minerals
through the through the rebound or the
mineral sticks
I I totally agree and uh when I'm
outside working hard and I come inside
and drink the rebound I also spray
because it's very sunny and hot out here
I'm sweating like crazy sometimes
itching in my skin I spray the plant
minerals all over my skin my I don't I
don't burn I don't get a sunburn from it
it calms the itching it's just fantastic
thank you so much
okay and of course
um
we've saved many lives by taking people
who are unconscious
it's just by rubbing the plant minerals
on them
and that brings them back to life
because they absorb the minerals through
the skin it's almost like intravenous
and these are people who were told but
you know by the doctors all this this is
the end
and we rub murals on them and it wasn't
I love that Dr well like and and I'm
like Phyllis I put it on a spray bottle
and I just spray my skin and it's so
refreshing
at any time of the day I mean even first
thing in the morning when I get up
I spray my hair my face my chest area
with plant dry minerals
um so maybe that's why it's all curly
and whatever
but I love the fact that we have those
plain plant Drive minerals and we also
have the Cherry mens which have a nice
cherry flavor we have the strawberry
kiwi men's which is strawberry kiwi
that's actually my favorite and then the
mineral sticks I love the mineral stocks
sticks Dr willick because I also get my
dose of collagen which helps with my
joints my tendons my skin
all of those things that require
collagen as a raw ingredient to to
thrive
so great option let's go to par who has
her hand up hello par welcome
let me hold on hold on hold on
something didn't quite glow right so
just a moment and there go ahead and
unmute
thank you hi doctor hello good to see
you again doctor I just got all the
supplement uh last two weeks I just
spoke with you on the zoom and I
whatever you advised me and I got it
nine of them and I started immediately
immediately to use and I love it
especially the enzyme and I had a
acidity reflects really bad I can say 50
percent it's gone I can see just a few
days yeah yeah I'm so happy doctor for
that and also I'm continuing all of them
and um hopefully I'm gonna get a better
result I have really good feeling about
all of them and this time doctor the
reason I just um when I talk to you
regarding my migraine doctor it is
really hurting me and last five days and
I had it in my head doctor for at least
five or four four hours a day and I
couldn't even walk and I I keep vomiting
Non-Stop and what can I do and also
doctor I'm just taking a vitamin B a B12
and vitamin 3 and also today I got
vitamin two and I B2 and I added you
know to take three of them okay how much
do you weigh how much you weigh
145 okay all right well in addition to
everything you're doing and I'm assuming
you've got the Healthy Start pack or the
healthy brain and heart pack one of
those right yes I did okay say good then
um to deal with uh stuff going on with
the headache migraines right yes okay
yeah we want you to take the
um
I I would go I would go with the
what would you start with Rebecca
well Dr Wallach we want to make sure
she's definitely getting uh synaptive
and MSM
okers
it is on my list
wonderful but a synaptive helps like
that and for my migraines
um I was taking extra plant dry minerals
the Changi Tangerine the Osteo FX
so that's came in your brain and heart
pack
um but make sure that you do not skimp
on those efas those essential fatty
acids
and your brain and heart pack you have
two different varieties and both of them
are very important
so
with the EFA plus it's a minimum one
three times a day with the ultimate EFA
two three times a day
I got that one three twice a day so just
keep keep going
keep going on that end yeah throw that
synaptive in there in the synaptic
okay okay I will do that I ordered that
one and Doctor the second question I do
have regarding the psoriasis for my
young daughter and it is around the ears
both of them and the skin is very flaky
doctor and do you recommend it any cream
anything she can apply to just keep the
you know the ski most tries okay I
missed that what's the matter with her
ears
yeah
okay well psoriasis of course is a skin
issue so what she needs of course is is
the
um she needs a collagen okay she's a
collagen peptides he's a hair skin and
Nails I go with the hair skin and Nails
also the CM cream topically it'll stop
the itching okay that same frame
behind her ears or around her ears
wherever that itching is but um the
uh
and then this kid is what eight years
old you say
no she's 20 doctor oh 20 okay so she can
be treated like an adult okay yeah the
synaptive all right I throw the synaptic
in there
and the excuse me uh the collagen
peptides the collagen peptides is going
to help
um the white matter of the brain grow
properly
okay
okay doctor okay and also doctor last
time I just asked you a question
small dog Chihuahua I do have and she
has all over the placket and also gum
disease what is their home remedy I can
yeah arthritics add to the dog food no
table scraps a good a good canned dog
food all the Barnes and minerals in it
and just follow the directions on the
label for the amount to feed that dog
and then the arthro decks it's one scoop
for 20 pounds of body weight so if the
dog weighs
um three pounds I would just give it
give it a half a scoop to start out with
and once things get better you kind of
reduce it down to the appropriate amount
but I've shared out with a half a half a
scoop okay okay God doctor is that it's
gonna help for the placket of the teeth
yes okay got it
yeah and the reason for that is because
the arthrodex has enzymes in it those
enzymes help to break through things
like the plaque on not just the teeth
that but everything within the digestive
system also and helps you break down the
food so that the nutrients are available
so great question thank you and Dr
Wallach it is time for you to be going
on to the other Airwaves with radio
thank you again so much for joining us
here on daily with Doc and folks thank
you for joining us if I could have my
co-hosts on the screen with me I just
want to say thank you so much Marilyn
for all that you do and putting in the
recommendations that Dr Wallach is
offering an additional information into
our chat so folks that's one of the
biggest benefits of being here with us
on our live daily with doc from daily
with doczoom.com is Marilyn and all of
her fine typing skills thank you Marilyn
and we have Phyllis who is helping let
people into the room today she's out on
Facebook and YouTube and Rumble and
commenting and sharing information there
and also so in the chat
and asking questions so as we have
people that are posting questions out on
those different platforms she's helping
me and getting those questions answered
also and then we have AJ who is keeping
track of all of our streams and on those
platforms making sure that everything is
running smoothly and
he helped me a lot with my computer
issues so today was much less stressful
thank you so much AJ for all of you do
and using your skills in what we call
Advanced team building where we're using
our individual skills to build and
promote something that is near and dear
to our heart and that is
Wellness folks your Wellness our
Wellness as we work together and I just
want to thanks I saw lots of other
people out on YouTube some additional
people that are part of our team
um and
youngevity Distributors I just
absolutely love it so make sure you
smash that like that heart share it with
other people and there was the question
that I wanted to answer that was in the
chat here and it has to do with the
difference between the tingy tangerine
and the Ultimate Classic two of our
amazing multivitamin multi-complex
products things that we offer now over
the years
formulas have been created to
specifically meet people where they're
at
so it's like evolved over the
generations and that's the main
difference it's just a little extra of
this or a little extra of that so folks
just like food
you have to read the labels
and look at what is in that as far as
the nutritional values of the different
things so if you have more bone concerns
you may want to go with something that
has more of those minerals that help
build bone calcium magnesium phosphorus
strontium all those things so you just
read labels they're both wonderful
wonderful products I've used both of
them over the last seven years and I
can't say anything negative about either
of them I am folks when you give your
body what it needs what it's thriving
for you don't have those Cravings that
you would another person had a question
here wanting to know because they're on
the program they're walking four to five
miles a day yet they're gaining weight
we want to remember muscle weighs more
than fat
so as you're doing all that walking and
exercising you are building muscle now
you got to look at okay what is causing
that for fat storage
do you have blood sugar concerns that
need extra attention
do you need to reevaluate your diet I
personally love the ketogenic diet
the ketogenic diet when done right it
turns your body into a machine that
burns fat for energy instead of sugar or
carbohydrates for energy
so a couple things to con to to consider
that I wanted to address as the
questions were coming in now Dr Wallach
had to get on to his next program and we
are always always always everything that
we promote on this show
is in accordance with Dr wallach's
teachings
he has all of the research he has the
knowledge he has clinical proof
that these things work and each of us on
the screen are evidence of it as well
so folks thank you so much for joining
us here on daily with Doc my name is
Becca dukes and on behalf of the crew
and the whole entire youngevity family
of
approaches and Distributors and
Associates if you were invited to this
program by somebody specific get back
with them if not
feel free to call us on our 800 number
855-949-3377 or go to the website use
the contact option
and send us an email let us know what
your health concerns are how you would
like to become involved that's a big
thing if you've got skills that you
would like to use to help promote this
Wellness Crusade let us know and we will
help you figure out how we can help you
get those being worked for you and your
community and together we help the world
until next time have a wonderful weekend
bye for now
recordings
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]